everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
make a landing page with react so we'll
be using material UI to help us out with
that if you don't know that much about
react don't worry feel free to ask as
many questions as you want and I'll do
my best to explain things and answer
your questions if you're new to the show
this is how it works I set a timer for
25 minutes and we do mostly code for 25
minutes and then we take a five-minute
break and I check the live chat and I'll
answer questions as many as I can in
five minutes then we'll do another 25
minute code session and then after that
I'll spend the rest of the stream
answering your questions so if you can
put a question in the chat and I'll
definitely see that if you can't for
whatever reason put a question in the
chat right now you could always add it
as a comment to this video or you could
ask me a question on any social media my
DMS are open and I do my best to get
back to you as soon as I can all right
let's get started I will show you my
screen let's get this code a little bit
bigger okay that might be an all right
size let me know if it's not and let me
show you here we go let's start out like
this you all will get to see my
excellent drawing skills okay here's the
basic outline for the page that we're
gonna build so we're gonna have a hero
section at the top above that will be
our hour at bar you know our top
navigation menu that we already have
we're going to do a hero section that's
going to be very similar to the one that
we did on the home page and
then I'd like to have a section with a
little bit of text maybe icons if we
have some icons that's gonna highlight
some of the programs on campus we're
gonna have whoa we're gonna have another
section that would highlight different
types of programs so these will be on
campus
online and then steps for how to apply
and these will be you know very brief
with links to the ways to apply and then
we're gonna have another section that
potentially could include things about
costs or we can include some of the main
selling points that seem to be seem to
resonate with our potential students so
this I worked for University in this
page is going to be the admissions
landing page so I actually did this
sketch after sitting down with the
graduate admissions people and seeing
what what they thought would work but
we're gonna do one for the undergraduate
admissions today but we're going to use
the same layout so we're gonna use a lot
of just sample data and then let the
people from admissions you'll give us
the content that we need to fill it out
later
some other things that we may want to
include are testimonials and other sales
points right so those could potentially
go here and might be like a quote from a
former student and a picture if we have
a picture of them so today we'll
probably just use you know whatever
whatever images we can find and whatever
quotes we can pull the most important
thing is getting something on the page
the layout something to look at because
I have a meeting with the people from
admissions coming up I think next week
and I need to show them something
because they're gonna be the ones that
are gonna approve whether or not this
site is ready to go live
because this is primarily a tool for
marketing to prospective students okay I
won't make you look at my sketch anymore
okay so for those of you who haven't
been following the stream this is kind
of a view of the homepage so this is
going to stay this top navigation our
hero section is going to look somewhat
similar to this we may end up going with
maybe like a smaller version of this the
this kind of thing I think is okay for a
homepage but for me personally it gets a
little annoying if I start seeing this
on a lot of interior pages
I'd rather get to the content so we may
cut down on the height and then we're
gonna have some similarities in the
sections and we may reuse some of these
elements that we've already made and
that'll save us some code but we'll
probably have to code some some new
stuff as well okay all right let me say
I got a lot of action in the chat oh
yeah a lot of people in here so I
imagine there are some new people
welcome so hey everyone just I'm not
gonna say hi to everybody individually
because there's a lot of people in here
right now but I just want to say hi and
I'll read through your comments in more
detail at the end of the stream okay
let's get the Palmer two hour timer
started and let me start up this end
Rock server so that you all can view
what I'm working on as I'm working on it
and you can inspect it in your browser
open up dev tools mess around with it
whatever you want
so go and click on that link if clicking
on the link doesn't work you may want to
try copy and pasting it sometimes the
live chat links don't work right if you
click alright it looks like it's working
for these some of you
so first things first we need to
actually create the page the component
page and we need to make a route to it
in our server das file and that's pretty
much gonna be the only back-end ish type
of stuff that we do really minimal all
its going to be all front-end stuff
today okay so whenever I create a new
component I always try to recycle code
from a previous component to cut down on
the amount of typing that needs to be
done so let's take a current page that
we're already using and we may as well
use the home page because we're gonna
use so much of what's already on the
home page so our home page should be
index yep index so I'm just going to
copy and paste everything from index j/s
and let's make a new file and we're
gonna call this admissions ojs and i
paste everything in there and we need to
change the name
to admissions okay other than that
everything should work and now we need
to point that that URL path for
admissions to the right place so let's
go to our server Jas file which I
usually have open there it is
and let's look up admissions admission
[Music]
there we go
here's admissions and we want to say our
default is gonna go to our defaults Nate
and now go to slash admissions so if
you're not sure what's going on here
don't worry about it where this is all
we're gonna do right now I guess the
only that's important to know is that
this just controls what components going
to render whenever we go to a certain
URL is so what did I do wrong
[Music]
what's it's elevating
that should be fine right
oops
default is admissions and then what's
the next thing this needs to be
secondary
right
okay remember the key words I use let me
double-check was standard
yeah sorry standard not sure what I was
thinking when I named it standard all
right there we are so I had to put that
in as well so that all the rest of the
pages we want to go to the page
component to be rendered for now this
one is just going to go through the
admissions page components and yeah and
this should work cool all right so let's
let's really test now and see if it does
work so we're gonna go to slash
admissions oh quick update for those of
you that have actually loaded this hey
it works awesome
it'd have actually loaded this project
onto your machine from github and links
in the description if you want to check
out the code on github it's all over the
source do what you want with it but if
you have downloaded it please pull in
the latest changes I did a lot of work
on Friday and like into Friday night and
I made some updates for the packages and
I had to update the version of node that
I was using so you may have depending on
what version of node you were currently
running it may not work anymore unless
you update so just a heads up on that
okay so we have our route to the
admissions face working which is great
last week
nothing works simple things broke and it
was a mess we're already at doing better
this week alright so now let's go into
the code and rip out the stuff that we
don't need and replace it with with some
other things so a lot of connections
open on end rock that's awesome shoutout
to inconceivable for giving us a free
unlimited
and for these rico camp live streams
with the end rock service okay so we're
done with that server ojs file and we're
just going to focus now on our
admissions file and let's give us give
ourselves a ton of space to work with
and let me double check I don't know if
anybody said anything about the font
size so let me know now if the font size
is too small increase it I'll try to
remember in about a minute to look back
at the chat okay so for now so if you're
not familiar with react let me just give
you a quick intro so a react component
is just like a chunk of code and it can
include your markup right like your HTML
Javascript and CSS all in one but the
HTML doesn't it looks kind of like HTML
but it has JavaScript blended in we call
that JSX
and your CSS may not look exactly like
normal CSS okay so in this case our CSS
is actually a JavaScript object what it
should look a bit familiar to you
there's just some difference like we
have some camel casing going on here and
we don't have semicolons at the end of
the line all right but other than that
these do exactly what you they would
normally do in CSS and we also are
pulling in code from a lot of other
places so all these imports at the top
we're pulling in other components and
other pieces of code to help us alright
so all we're doing is saying we want to
import this thing and we're going to
call it typography in this case and
we're going to get it from here and here
is where we put in the path and the
filename all right so these are all the
styles we're going to keep those as is
for now and we'll edit those later on
when we need to all right here's how
we're going to start out with so we have
this hero component and that's for our
hero section that we see here
so a long time ago we months ago we
abstracted out that hero component in
into its own little component because we
assumed like we're probably going to
need to use this again for another page
well we finally have to use it again for
another page so good thing we did that
for now I'm going to keep this image
because I don't have another image in
mind just want to keep it like this but
eventually we'll change it out and we're
just going to change out a little bit of
the text and we're gonna see about
setting the height I don't know if I
built that in yet or not so we'll check
that component out see if it's built in
if not we'll build something into the
component to allow us to really easily
change the height if you joined a little
bit late I'm not ignoring your questions
for for good we're gonna reset a timer
and so in about 15 minutes I'm gonna get
to all the questions so if you can stick
around for a bit I will answer it this
stream will also be recording recorded
and it will be available to watch the
replay on this channel with free code
camp channel so if you miss something
don't worry you can always watch it
again so let's change this to
we're gonna change it to undergraduate
admissions and then below this I'm just
gonna leave the the tagline for the
University which is academically
excellent passionately Catholic so it's
a Catholic school run by Franciscans and
you know what I want to keep these
buttons because these are the main
things that admissions would want you to
do apply enquire a visit so we can keep
those buttons so a lot of that it's nice
it can stay the same so we'll save that
and then let's go to that hero component
so let me close up some of these folders
so it's not so cluttered okay so here's
our components and where's our hero
there we are
I mean it's an alphabetical order
shouldn't be that hard right all right
so here's our hero component and here's
where we get our height from this this
min height of 80 VH so the VHS viewport
height so if you see a t think 80% of
the screen height so I do want to drop
that down but right now we don't really
have a way to drop that down through our
props right so these are the things that
we pass in so if you see here we passed
in all this data into the component
these are called props so we want to
make a prop that could give us the
height so let's see
let's just call it min min height so
it'll be really clear what it is
we'll say min height and for this one I
want to pass in let's go 66 tbh we'll
see how that looks all right so we're
passing it in now but we're not doing
anything with it over here so over here
I'm gonna say men whoops
men Heights okay so we're using object
destructuring here so that we don't have
to keep typing in and this props over
and over again so all of our props are
here
just nice to have a list of all the
props anyway and then down here we're
gonna find the spot where we've we're
putting this these styles so parallax is
the class that we've given it so let's
see where we have parallax these are all
our buttons here we go parallax so what
we'll do we already are overriding a
style here for the background image so
we're just going to do it again and
we're gonna add a style so this is
similar to the normal style attribute
that you can give an element in HTML
right but instead we have these brackets
the first set of brackets says hey we're
gonna write some JavaScript the second
set of brackets since we're in
JavaScript now indicates a JavaScript
object so again like it was above we
have our CSS in the form of a JavaScript
object okay and we're gonna do just like
we did here we're gonna make use of
template literals which is an es6 es2015
thing that allow us to mix strings with
javascript without having to concatenate
a bunch of plus signs so this will do so
let's put in min heights and then we'll
use actually what we need to know we
won't because we we've put it all
together so we should be able to just
add in let's see if that works
I'm a little bit minutes not too fine
hmm it's not gonna like me saying me all
right so let's see let's say minimum
Heights about that in that'll avoid
confusion and minimum Heights
minimum Heights and then we'll go back
here and add in minimum right so now
there will be no confusion between the
the CSS that says men height and our
variable that we passed in as a prop
that's it's men minimum height okay
let's check it out now hey it worked
right so you could see it used to be
down here now it's much smaller so I
like that for now
maybe I'll go a little bit smaller we'll
see it definitely depends on the image
that we end up using as whether or not
that image will even work with these
kind of dimensions yeah but you can see
when we do that it's definitely a
percentage of the of the screen so it
changes as we move things around just
about ten more minutes and then I'll get
to the questions all right awesome
so that part of this is for now done
right but we need we definitely need to
get some input on the image and the text
to put here but I believe the buttons
and undergraduate admissions will be
fine all right so for this next part
let's let's go ahead and set it up for
testimonials I think testimonials are
good let me think about it when you go
to Amazon and you look at a product you
usually scroll down and see what people
say about it at least I know I do right
I want to make sure
okay this product looks cool I checked
the price first and I check to see if
it's prime so I get that free shipping
right and then the very next thing I
check is I scroll down and see you know
what did what did people say so I think
that would also be useful if a student
is potential student is looking at
Franciscan University and they say all
right well I know all the marketing
stuff they're putting out there but what
other people say all right
of course we're only going to put the
good stuff on our website for reviews
but you know that's how it goes so let's
take let's take these this style of of
card and let's reuse this style for our
testimony our testimonials so we'll do
an image and then quote and we're
probably we're not gonna have a link
right so depending on the content we get
maybe this could end up being an entire
page but for now I'm just gonna assume
we just have a really small quote and a
small image and that's it and we'll try
to go three across on a large screen of
course they'll stack on mobile also as
I'm going through if if any of you have
suggestions for for what I'm doing or if
you see me doing something wrong let me
know alright so let's figure out what
this what component this is it looks
like
profile card great so this is profile
card and let's grab let's grab this
whole thing because these are there's
two profile cards in here already
I'm just going to take this out to
profile cards in there already and so
that'll be good that's what we want and
let's make a container so we're going to
put it in right here
so for our container we're just going to
make a div and we're gonna give it a I'm
sorry we're gonna do a grid this is
something that comes with material UI if
you're not familiar with react think of
material UI is like like bootstrap is
right or materialized CSS is for you
know like a normal website look at
JavaScript just vanilla JavaScript site
so what material UI does is it gives us
a set of styles and components that we
can use and it keeps the consistent
material design feel to the site so
we're going to use this grid and we're
going to call it we're going to give it
the attribute or prop up container
alright so we want to container grid
wood and close that out as well oops
okay let me double check and make sure
it's supposed to be container I think it
is I don't know why I didn't have a
container earlier okay so we made a
great container and now we have these
grid items inside of here and I want to
try to do three items so let's add a
third one and notice when we have this
grid that I may end up taking this class
off we'll have to see what's in there
but for our other props we're saying we
have extra small small medium and large
these are screen sizes so we're telling
it how many columns out of twelve to
take up on a particular screen size so
right now we're taking up the full width
twelve columns on an extra small screen
and on all other screen sizes we're
taking up half the width well that
worked when we only had two but now we
have three so that's definitely not
going to work so let's change this up
and let's try four right so four columns
will allow us to have three items right
side by side so let's see how that looks
all right there we go so there's our
three cards side by side okay
so a few things to note I think we can
go a bit smaller with these with these
cars and I don't know that I like them
being so wide across
I would prefer maybe a bit more margin
on the sides and I don't like that
they're not the same heights so other
than that they're showing up properly
let's shrink this down all right you see
and they didn't stack up when we shrink
them down okay so they basically behave
the way that they're supposed to okay I
do want to check out what kind of CSS
we're adding here so let's let's find
our class called grid item fix there we
are servicing with 100% Patti okay
there's nothing there that would really
mess up anything that we're doing so I'm
gonna leave it like that what I think we
we ought to do though is add this
content container in all right this will
give us that padding on the sides that
we want and you see depending on the
screen size we'll have like more or less
padding so we're not actually adding
like padding right like we would do a
CSS padding we're just setting the
maximum width to a percentage so it it
seems like padding right and on a
smaller screen we have less on the sides
which makes sense because we want to be
able to display more content on a small
screen but on a large screen you know
the content would be huge the images
would be way too big which is exactly
what we have going on here so let's grab
this content container I'm just gonna
copy that and then I'm going to come
down here to our grid container and
we're giving it a give it a class name
of we're gonna say classes and I'll
paste that in there we are
so the styles should all be applied now
all right awesome so now you see we have
much smaller images yet this works I
definitely want to try to find images of
students where so like this type of
image will work where it's primarily the
the student you see the student when we
have this one where you know the image
is primarily the background right this
this hallway it doesn't work quite as
much because the images are now a bit
smaller so probably want to switch out
these images of course we're gonna have
different students but for now this will
work let's just remove these links
though I don't want the links right now
and we built these components so that I
believe we should be able to remove this
prop for link and and once we remove the
prop it just won't display that link
anymore
okay so otherwise if you try to do that
you haven't built that in wood you may
end up with is an error because it'll be
looking for data that's not there and I
might throw an error so let's say that
and this would be the last thing we
check before you are the questions yep
there we go no errors alright so got the
hero section and that first section
pretty much laid out notice I'm not
doing any really detailed stuff that'll
come on the second pass when we really
get into things also before I have final
approval it's almost a waste of time to
go into the details and try to fix
everything you know we could spend hours
you know just on this
action getting everything perfect and
then I'll go into a meeting and find out
they don't want that section at all when
we throw it out right okay let me do a
break I'm gonna scroll all the way up to
the top of the chat and just go down so
if you ask your question recently I may
not get to it this time but I'll get to
it at the end of the stream Sherman said
before the stream even started is it a
static website Vennela react you're
gonna use things like Gatsby hopefully
vanilla we're using next Jas so it's not
exactly vanilla react but next doesn't
add in a whole lot of extra stuff so in
terms of how we design the components
themselves it's it's pretty much vanilla
react unless you know if you want to
count the tour UI obviously that's not
vanilla everyone so what are you saying
hi more assess what live stream software
I'm using OBS so OBS is free and I
believe it's available for Windows Mac
and Linux so check it out if anybody has
questions about how I do my settings for
OBS let me know I can screenshot my
settings okay one us when I'm building
and I think I kind of covered that so
hopefully answer your question one if
you still have questions about what I'm
building let me know
miss Sara says you use Gatsby for
project five-day - did you use further
Gatsby for project five or use Gatsby
just for projects holiday - we ended up
not using Gatsby and we went with next
Jas it fit the requirements of a project
better and I was more familiar with it
so we ended up one with next so we
didn't use Gatsby for that project but
we still have the Gatsby branch
available so if you wanted to go back
and you use that as a basis for a
project feel free it may be a bit
outdated now since that was six months
ago
all right Michael creo says don't put
cost on the front page maybe don't but
don't put it on the page that can be
added with SEO maybe add a link to it
yeah you know what one thing is for our
graduate program the price is is a
really good price so we want to put the
cost for that because it's a big selling
point our undergrad program is
definitely a good price for a private
education but it's it's not something
that people say wow this is really cheap
school so we don't really want to add
that as you know advertise that college
cost so much money that even if it's a
good price it still seems like a lot so
we don't really want to put that on
there and you're definitely right
Michael I'm not trying to hide it from
anybody but you don't just want that to
stand out on the very first page Steven
says amazing art totally makes sense
worst handwriting ever yeah for sure I
type I type I don't need to write on
paper right one says give me the link to
get your source code it's in the
description so just kind of scroll down
and check check the link in the
description
crystal says what language you coding
this with this is JavaScript in
particular it's react which is a library
that helps us build progressive web apps
in JavaScript and you can build other
things with it as well
see
one says cool I'm gonna clone your web
with the source code awesome
see crystal says what's the name of your
editor it is Visual Studio code so I see
joby thanks for answering that in the
chat what type of font are you using for
the website itself we're using Roboto
and then for my editor its feet fyra
font or fear of font I'm not sure how to
pronounce that
Fira and that is Michael Michael added
in the chat it's Visual Studio code with
the seti theme so seti is the theme that
I'm using Christopher says good font
size alright awesome I'm glad that I'm
glad you all can see that oh well
Michael so you might want to add that
and rock shout out to your YouTube
description for the stream that's X
that's a really great idea
maybe I'll write up something about that
okay
I'm gonna mark down where I'm leaving
off at in the chat cuz my timer just
went up and that way I can come right
back to it after we do another 25
minutes of code okay so if I didn't get
to your question now apologies but I
definitely will get to it after the next
25-minute coding session let's start
this up okay and let me put the link
into this Pomodoro clock this was built
by Harshit who frequently watches the
stream not here today though but it's a
nice Pomodoro clock so go ahead and a
few a few others of you that watch the
stream also it made really awesome
Pomodoro clocks so I'll shout out your
clocks if you want me to just let me
know okay over yet
wait a second what's your seven
there we are
all right let's let's go into the next
section then like I said I don't want to
be too detailed about this so let's see
so we said that our next section was
going to be our programs now this would
work for our graduate programs because
we don't have so much so many programs
but for our undergrad programs I don't
think that layout would work so let's
think of another way we could do this
I'm thinking we need to break this out
into categories so let's see if we can
keep
I definitely want to break it out into
we can do three categories that would
work we can do five categories we can do
six categories I think any of those
combinations would work just in terms of
laying things out on a screen so it
would look
it would look okay so you know what
let's take a look let's take a look at
our page that lists all of our our
undergraduate programs so it should be
ug majors alright so this is just the
list that's come maybe that's not it
maybe it's oh no it's automatically
sending us here now all right I'm not
gonna worry about that now because I
don't want to get into the the server
stuff more but off to fix that after so
let's go here
academics ug majors alright that'll
actually work academics that makes sense
okay
there we are okay so here's all the
majors that we currently have so I'm
wondering I don't know how many that is
but we definitely could split things up
although we could go through like
humanities or Sciences I mean that's
definitely a a.split we can do social
sciences as a as a split all right let's
try this split let's try humanities
science and social science and then I'll
we'll all let admissions figure out what
categories to put what in oh Michael
Chris at 53 Oh
53 majors okay that's gonna be a lot
let's see how it looks
I mean you have business business
business business
yeah I'm gonna I'm just gonna put these
categories down as an example of what
could be so that we can show it at the
meeting all right so let me let's go
back to this page we can visualize this
so I'm envisioning like let's say five
categories so we would have like one two
three and then four or five would be in
between in these spaces so we'll have
bigger gaps here but they'll kind of
split the difference and what we'll have
is essentially lists
I'm not hundred percent sure that this
is is gonna work is it that in terms of
is it it's gonna look good but I think
it's worth a shot I think it'll give the
students very quick access to more
information about what they want to do
and it'll let them know right off the
bat you know here's what the majors we
have here's what we offer right our
products is based off of majors so I
think that's a great thing to put out
there right away here's what we offer
here's all the flavors of college that
we offer here right
okay so let's just grab this grid that
we just made and let's add this in here
could we do yeah let's at it here we may
we may not well this will work for now I
may want to change this up a bit later
on but no sense in trying to refactor
anything right now
did I get everything there we are
okay so instead of profile cards let's
get rid of these profile cards for now
we're gonna create essentially our our
own thing and if we really like it we
want it to work we'll make it our
component but for right now I don't have
a component that does what I want it to
do already so let's just go with this
let's do a actually we just did this
somewhere we might be able to copy and
paste what page did we just do this on
okay y'all that I some of you were there
for that stream I know I was asking
about how to correctly put a heading on
a list in a way that screen readers
would understand what page was that what
were you working on I can't remember if
anybody remembers let me know in the
chat and we can copy that for now I'll
just make this list cuz I know we need
the list you well let's do a few L eyes
and I wish I had a mitt in here I'm not
sure if I have M it in here hold on
aside I forget how to do it anyway
the education page is that it the one
with the courses yep that's it that is
it where is it a sample schedule yes
awesome section that's how we did it we
did section that's what we want
okay so it's good to always have
accessibility in mind and by that I mean
like mainly screen readers so they'll be
able to see it but not just screen
readers also like the correct contrast
between your fonts and your backgrounds
good font sizes so let's add this as
we'll just go with h4 it's just like we
did before and we can even pull over the
styles as well let's see I'm not gonna
put anything in these for now let's see
so if we have about 50 majors and we're
gonna have five of these categories then
I need like 10 items in here 2 4 6 8 10
okay why is my my indentation is crazy
well it'll the indentation will get
fixed on save okay so for this grid item
yeah this will actually work this this
will work as is we just need to copy
this over a few times should this get
rid of these so let's copy this
you know we may as well make let's fill
in something so we can actually see it
on the page there yeah
the three one two three four five so for
these ones down here these grids we're
going to switch this up and we're gonna
leave as four but we want to offset them
okay so let's look up how we make do
this offset grid so we're gonna check
out grid this is material UI I'm gonna
put the link in here to where I'm
looking this up in the chat that way you
can check this out as well so I'm
assuming there's an offset because that
seems like something people would want
right let's okay so we may there's no
offset built in we could just add a an
empty grid grid tag let's let's check
the API and see what we have
all right let's try this
so I want a grid so this is one two
three so in between three and four let's
put another grid let's remove everything
though I actually don't need this ending
so let's remove everything and on
extra-small let's say it's zero I don't
know that we can actually put zero in
there if that's valid but I don't want
this to take up any space if you know if
we're on a small screen so I may be able
to get away with putting one in there
we'll see we'll see how it works but if
zero works and that's what I want to go
with first so we're going to zero but
then on a small screen I want to do it
like this
so we're gonna have our two larger
sections that we want to see that are
going to be visible and they're gonna be
four and four that makes eight right so
that gives us a whole nother for that we
have to fill up that space so that's why
we're gonna make this one two and that's
going to be the beginning and then at
the end we're gonna add another blank
grid grid item that's also gonna take up
two columns all right let's see what
happens I'm kind of expecting an error
but whoa no error all right so good to
know you can put zero as a grid item and
let's double check and make sure that
actually works so this is extra small
screen size awesome awesome
great okay so that's what we have
doesn't look good at all
right now but let's bring over our
styles that we had already figured out
went on another component and that way
yeah
we'll see what it looks like after so I
was just kind of looking at the spacing
like maybe we should Center this stuff
because it's all over to the side but
let's add our Styles first and then see
what we can do so on the sample schedule
component that we made last week we had
this grid item so on the grid itself we
had a style of list grid item on our UL
we had styles list on our h4 we had list
header and then our Li we had list item
so we're gonna copy over quite a few
Styles here so this grade item list list
header and list item list item list was
tighter than this good item area
alright let's copy all of those and
we'll put them up here with the rest of
our Styles it looks like we already have
a list item list I'll type none
let's say let's just call it major major
list item we just change that up a bit
and then now on these we can add in our
class names so let's see we can probably
get rid of this grid item fix because
that was for a different issue so I
doubt we need that anymore and actually
you know what let's get rid of these
first because we don't need any styles
on on these ones
all right there we are
so we're going to replace grid fix item
with list grid item that we just pulled
over we can check out what these styles
are actually doing you know when we we
get them all switched over
but for now
you
for now I think it's better to see it
first and then we'll explain explain it
after you do class name classes dot list
and then there's a ul or H fours we're
gonna get
really should have done this before I
copied them all whoops
that would have been smarter
last name equals classes whoops that's
not an equal sign equals classes dot
list header
all right and then finally allies that's
a lot of allies we can do this we're
going to test the limits of multiple
cursors and we change that didn't we
list item we change it to major list
item right
all right there we go class name equals
classes dot major list item that looked
really cool I mean I don't know that
just look cool editing all those lines
all at once so hopefully I didn't mess
it up let's save it and see what it
looks like all right not too much
different really but we don't have any
of those those bullets anymore let's try
to Center this at least
yeah it's gonna be a little bit
difficult let's see
well again let's just let's try the easy
part first okay about five more minutes
less than five minutes I'm gonna go back
to the questions okay so let's see
see if we can just do a
text-align:center yeah we can awesome
see we can do a center that's great we
can do it on here as well this what I
was talking about the easy thing okay we
could do it the easy way and just have
them all centered you know what for now
let's let's go with that okay I I don't
normally like to have centered things
like this I think it looks kind of weird
to have it like different starting
points for the lines so the way around
that would be if that does look really
weird to try to just censor the list
inside of of the div but we can already
see like kind of an issue right because
we're already full width so probably end
up using some I don't know what I'd use
but I'm not gonna worry about it now
this should be enough that once we get
some real names of the courses in here
it'll be alright but I'm not gonna type
out manually all the names of all of
these right that's that would be crazy
yeah I just did this manually just so we
could get a nice look of what we're
doing right so at first we're gonna
build this out and it is gonna be a lot
of markup here but then eventually all
this data will be pulled in from our
content management system so there
really will be nothing but just the bare
bones in this component so you wouldn't
you want to normally want to leave it
like that
where you have so much going on you know
in one component
okay
all right and I should only have a few
minutes left two minutes all right what
do we do for two minutes
I know we do for two minutes we commit
this stuff so I don't forget so you get
status all right we can see what we've
done we've edited the hero component we
added the functionality to be able to
pass in the minimum height as a prop all
right we worked on the server just to
get the route 1 where we wanted and then
we've also added in this new component
admission CAS so let's get add and I'm
gonna just add in a dot because that
puts everything in there
wait Nietzsche says github is down whoa
github is down
it's working for me maybe it's just down
regionally let me know is it down
how many people have github down right
now let me know in the chat I mean I'm
gonna try to push either way but
okay so it is working for some people
well hopefully it'll work for us okay so
we're gonna add a little commit message
here to be a new feature and say add
admissions page component
alright this that works
all right and my time he was just
starting to go off so that means I have
about 20 seconds left
so we have something set up here that it
will automatically format our code and
it will run some tests assuming
everything passes then we're good to go
with this commit so if you do want to
work on this on your own computer then
just be aware that all this will happen
when you try to commit using yarn cm
instead of the normal method of
committing it looks like everything
passed and let's see if we can get this
to push to github hey it worked ok so
I'm guessing maybe github is down
regionally I mean that kind of makes
sense it would be odd if github goes
down everywhere but I mean not unheard
of but okay all right so that's the the
timer for y'all didn't hear the time I
heard the timer so anyway timers up so
now I'm gonna go to the chat and pick up
where you left off and answer all the
questions that are there it's about 2
o'clock p.m. Eastern time so it's my
time I have a meeting at 3 p.m. so I can
answer questions for about 45 minutes if
I have that many questions
all right so let's get to it
okay so Phoenix asks a little bit about
an grok like the how and why of it so
and Rock is a service that allows you to
run something locally on your machine
share a link and then somebody else can
see what you're working on as you're
working on it so you make changes you
save it in your editor it automatically
shows up on their screen so you can
imagine this would be really useful for
like showing a client updates you know
potentially if if your pair programming
or something like that and you want to
see I'm say like pair programming
remotely right and you want to be able
to see the changes you know immediately
I have the other person see the changes
immediately and be able to inspect it
and dev tools right it works and it
works out really well for this live
stream so that you all also have access
to all the changes immediately without
me having to push it to a server
somewhere how that works internally I
have no idea
Jovie says have you done a high fidelity
prototype you mean like like a sketch
file this interactive type of prototype
no we didn't I don't remember if we did
some of that earlier on but at this
point no I just go right from the little
sketch I did and we have enough
components that we can kind of go right
into this to be honest with you it's
faster for me to just throw up some code
like this and adjust it a little bit
than to do this in sketch or something
like sketch so as long as if I was doing
some like really different design it
probably wouldn't be the case but with
with these design elements and material
design in general I've worked with it so
much that it is faster for me just to
code things and with material UI we have
so many pre-built things so I didn't I
didn't really see the need to do a
prototype first
all right Divya says hello everyone
after getting out 40-plus interviews
with node and Express I finally started
learning react and also bought Steven
critters course on udemy I've read a few
media mill articles as well awesome
that's really awesome congratulations
let's see Christmas's looks really weird
on laptop sighs all right I don't
remember what part looks weird the whole
thing or a specific part of the page let
me know Divi s asked if I had a haircut
I did I got a haircut laughs last week I
told him to go really short so it still
looks like it's a fresh haircut thanks
for noticing what do you all think
haircut
good bad let me know in the chat it's
super-important which I'll think about
my haircut
Chris says no the smaller viewport
height on the admissions page oh okay so
you're saying the hero section with a
smaller height looks weird okay yeah I
could see how potentially if we had a
wider screen that was a little bit short
it might look weird I I really think
it's what it's going to happen is this
going to end up depending on what image
we have here and we'll adjust the height
to fit the image but we'll see
alright it says there's bad there's no
subtitles yeah sorry about that I don't
know how we would subtitle a live a live
stream
I mean potentially if we get somebody to
add subtitles afterwards at least the
recordings can be subtitled but
unfortunately I only speak English
alright DVS says please suggest some
kind of learning approach I should be
open to while going forward or three-act
yes the best advice I have for learning
and this is not just with react but
everything is try to do a little bit
every day
so it's always fresh in your mind if you
can avoid it you know don't do like
every Saturday I'm gonna do a bunch of
stuff and then I'm not gonna do anything
else with it all week right you will
forget so much you know you'll learn but
not nearly as fast as if you broke that
down instead of doing like 8 hours on
Saturday you did you know about an hour
every day
so I'd stick to something like that and
then just be consistent with it
michael says i was wondering whether you
could use that card theme on the faculty
list page also it would keep the site's
theme consistent yeah we might be able
to yeah I didn't think about that but
you're right we could definitely just
use cards for the faculty oh oh yeah
I'll consider that I mean we already
have that page done so I'd hate to go
back and do more since there's so much
else to do but I kind of do like that
that suggestion Christopher says the
spacing between the cards and the banner
above them is different the spacing
between the cards and the banner should
be larger or equal to the spacing
between the cards okay cool yeah let me
stuff like that like I said we're not
gonna worry about details right now but
I am interested in stuff like that so
especially like if you see issues like
that and you have time please make a an
issue on github on the github repo and
then that way I can go back and check
those out
Aniki says I don't put much stock in
testimonials a website puts their
themselves they're gonna cherry pick
most of them most of the time it still
makes sense to put them there
yeah you're right you're right thanks
for sure divya says do you like those
cards to open as modal's like the design
Cora had some time back but they changed
it back to normal for you and the answer
sometimes I like these using modal's and
sometimes not I it just kind of depends
on what content the content we're
willing to and potentially so if there's
not really a lot of content a modal does
make sense but if there's enough content
for a separate page I like having a
separate page with its own URL just for
for SEO purposes I like that
michael says put the cards in a div then
adding a line items stretch to the div
should make them all the same height
shouldn't it yeah you know what Michael
I I know we've handled this issue before
so I was kind of thinking of just going
back to some of the older code and
seeing like how did we fix that but
you're right it's gonna be something
like that that'll make all these the
same what'll end up happening though is
you know there'll be some space at the
bottom so no matter what it's gonna look
a little audit but I'd rather have white
space below this and the card come down
here then to obviously have the cards be
different it's it's slightly less weird
to have the same height of the cards
with white space at the bottom of the
card
let's see Krister Braun says 15 to 1
student faculty ratio is not centered
vertically yeah you right it does look a
little bit off huh yeah like that's
another thing that's like a perfect
issue right because that's an easy fix
that either I could clean up one day
when I will have a few minutes and I try
to get you know just figure out
something I can do in five minutes or if
somebody else especially somebody who's
a beginner wants to contribute to a
project they can pick that up and you
know submit a pull request for that as
well
to one I'm not sure how to pronounce
that correctly but tu a an with a little
symbol over top of the a it says view
react or angular which do you like I
like reacts I haven't used angular since
angular 1 was out and I wasn't that
great with it I don't think it was
angular's fault I think it was just my
inexperience I haven't tried view but
I've heard good things so really I can
only I only have experience with reacts
so but I do really like using react new
sources do we need to connect project
one two three or should we follow
project five yeah all the projects are
separate projects so you don't have to
go through project one two and three
you could go to directly to project five
if you like or you could you know you
just check out video titles and and see
if there's certain topics that you want
to learn more about but each project is
slightly different in terms of the
technology that we've used so maybe you
know just want to check out each project
to see what we're using and then you
know watch the one that you're most
interested in
noble savage says hi oh hi Jesse love to
all hey how's it going thanks for
joining us
see
Krister says add a search function a
simple filter are we talking about a
search for majors I kind of I want them
to be displayed so I mean we already
have like a site-wide search but you can
actually click to say like I just want
to search for majors so that's already
there you know and it's already going to
be accessible from this page but here is
more like look at all the stuff we have
so I kind of want users to be able to
see it all I'm assuming that that's what
you're talking about was the the list of
majors
Hill says wood is react I'm new here
react is a JavaScript library that helps
you to build progressive web apps so
it's kind of hard to explain if you want
to get into more detail you check out
the react website you could read a lot
about it
but you know the short story is it's
just another way to make to build
websites or apps using javascript so
it's just kind of like a certain pattern
and way of you know building your app
like who says we've been working on the
search for months and still haven't got
it looking good yeah we're gonna have to
go back to the search soon we I finally
have part of the reason why we put it on
hold is I didn't have the data set up
like I needed to for the search to
actually be like 100% functional but now
I do have the data set up so now it
makes more sense to go back in and
finish it and try to make it look as
good as we can
see
Julio says you use any react extension
to format JSX automatically yeah we have
some Auto formatting going on with es
lint like on on save with the visual
studio code plugins and we also have
using what is it husky prettier in ES
lint whenever we commit it Auto formats
the code so no matter what code kind of
code you write if you go to commit it
it's going to format it in the style
that that we like which is we're using
standard standard Jas style which is
kind of nice because you can do it
however you want in terms of you know
tabs spaces semicolons no semicolons it
doesn't matter
it'll all be put into the same style
once it gets committed
okay cool Nikki says using the extra
small zero like we did here would
probably be the same thing as false
sincere as a false e value cool I didn't
think about it I mean I the way it
worked so that's that's cool but yeah
you're right
michael says since you know they're
working delete all but one moderate and
then copy and paste that yeah oh you
mean all these lists yeah yeah I'll do
that I mean I just we didn't have time
today during the stream but that's the
the next step is basically getting rid
of all of these turning one of them into
a component so it'll be in its own
component and then importing that
component and just iterating over the
data which will probably pull the data
in from a content management system
which we happen to be using WordPress
and we'll use graph QL or the REST API
to pull the data in we'll just map over
at all it'll come in in JSON format and
then it'll put out onto the page as many
of these as we want and we won't have to
have it cluttered up with with all this
markup it'll basically just be like this
you know one line with a couple of props
and that way this component will stay
you know nice and small easily readable
if you want to see like how to do
something like that you can check out
some of the previous videos I'm pretty
sure we just did that exact thing last
week
and see okay Chris or says the code
you're writing is redundant store at
least an array of arrays and iterate
yeah yeah that's exactly right
Chris's use dot map yeah Christopher
that's so if you check out our other
components that's exactly what we've
what we've been doing so I guess a good
example is like our drawer menu so the
entire side navigation menu is it's here
as an array of objects and then you know
when it actually you know the actual
component is just one component that
just gets printed out you know over and
over again but when I'm what I'm trying
to nail down the design I always like to
do it like this first because it just
gives me a lot more control it I don't
have to worry about all the props are
passing in and things like that it's
just you know I'm just putting markup on
the page and I'm editing it you know
it's it's really simple once I have it
to the point where it's like okay I like
this you know I think I'm definitely
gonna go with this then I turn it into a
component and then after that we can
always edit it a bit but for now it's
just kind of testing it out you know my
name is like don't make another
component if you're not sure if you even
need that that on the page yet if you're
even going to use it
all right ladies singing so Phoenix is
saying instead of selecting all the Li
tags one by one you could use command
control G what so what does that do
what's the command controls G do
last my place or it autoscroll me down
to the bottom
okay so officially it seems like github
is working now for most of you so maybe
it was down briefly amir says we can
have some fake data objects for now
until we get to CMS ready yeah we could
I mean since I already have this data in
the CMS I think it'd be okay yeah we
could just pull it from the CMS but for
now I was really more worried about like
what would my idea for aligning these
even look right at all would it look
terrible so that was kind of more what
we were trying to get there but I would
actually like to see it with the real
the real data so that will probably be
after I turn it into its own component
the next step would then be to pull in
the real data David said how did you
fill in those Li simultaneously okay so
we used I don't know what the shortcut
is on ever for everything but I can
select this text and then on a Mac I
press command D and it selects the next
instance of that particular string you
know all the way down so I can keep
selecting it so normally you only use it
for like two or three things in this
case I don't know I thought it was kind
of cool to try it out on a bunch of
things just to see how it worked and it
worked fine there was no lag or anything
so and it looked I thought it kind of
looked cool to have it all typing out so
yeah normally I would probably do a find
and replace if it were more but it just
so happened it was pretty easy to just
go away down with the with command D
lenovo says how you doing Jesse it's me
Anna I am doing well I always enjoy your
stream enough how come your name's
Lenovo yoga now on here anyway thanks
for watching and I'm glad you're doing
well
it also says nice nice haircut Thanks
see
Ahmir says can we get that live link
sure the end rock link yeah sorry about
that I pasted it in earlier but I'm not
sure if those of you who joined later
can see it or not so I'll paste that in
again and we also have the dev site
which is not quite as up-to-date but we
have our dev site available too and
that's it shouldn't be that slow I'm
pretty sure I said it to always have an
instance open with next so it shouldn't
have to load up a new instance anyway
michael says don't adjust the height to
fit the image adjust the image to fit
the height well what I was thinking
Michael is it's possible that I might
have to put a certain image in like
somebody higher up than me might say you
have to use this image and then I'll be
stuck with an image so I'll have to make
it work so yeah so I may not have the
ability to choose what image I want
Phoenix says what exactly is firebase
and flutter
okay so firebase is a Google service I
people is it normally used for apps as
like like a database for apps I'm not
sure what people normally use it for but
I'm I think it's normally for apps so
it's it's like a database-as-a-service
thing flutter so flutter is really new
as far as I know and I haven't learned
very much about it at all
what I'm pretty sure it's a way to make
apps and that's that's about all I know
so I haven't learned anything about
flutter yet other than that and that
might night of it might not be the case
so don't take my word for it
Christopher Brown says no reason to use
cards for faculty this in my opinion
okay cool yeah like I said I think I
probably won't put the cards in now just
because we have so much other stuff to
work on and the faculty list looks okay
right now
so for those of you who haven't been
following the project this is a very
very big site so the strategy right now
is to get all the data there make sure
it's accessible and seo-friendly
and it looks decent and it's fast step 2
after we launch is to go into each
section meet with the people at the
University who would be in charge of
each section like you know that's their
department or the professors that teach
these courses and then figure out how we
can best style things and what content
we should put on there to make it as
good as it can be so we'll kind of
slowly go through there and then train
those people to edit the content through
WordPress so the old website is just so
slow and it's not great on mobile that
any pretty much anything we do will be a
big improvement so if it seems like I'm
being a bit sloppy with the details I
mean that's that's kind of the point is
that we just need this thing to be done
and it doesn't need to be perfect
because it's you know within the next
few months we're gonna be going through
some sections and changing them
completely
alright thirsty pooch says I have got a
question
when using nodejs on windows and some
exercises which include such as gulp
when I try to run go up
I get module not found why is this
should I use yarn get module not found
when you try to run go up I guess you'd
need to have make sure you have gulp
installed you would yeah you shouldn't
you should definitely run npm install or
yarn first to make sure that it's gulp
is installed that would be my guess i'm
it's hard to say without you know seeing
the project see what's going on but yeah
definitely make sure that you act you do
have gulp installed like try and your
command line running gulp and then
putting space - v to see if it'll give
you your version of gulp if it doesn't
then maybe gulps honest though
let's see
see
I think I'm almost through you checked
my time ok still pretty good on time so
I may be able to answer a few more
questions before my meeting
Ahmir says I tried angular react in view
and in my experience I found view better
you can say it's the best of both worlds
alright that's interesting I definitely
like to try view at some point it's just
you know all my projects now have been
react to kind of make sense for me to
just try to get better at react because
I have a lot of things now that I'm
gonna have to maintain you in react but
maybe for a side project or something
but small something small I could try
out you Dex Troyer of world says SAS or
styled components I haven't decided on
what my favorite way to style react
components is honestly I've tried a few
different ways and I just I keep trying
more ways so within the same project
I've done like two or three different
ways I'm still trying to decide
Ivo says what's p5d 88 that's project 5
day 88 so this is the fifth project
we've done on this live stream and it is
day 88 of the project we really stream
88 so I don't stream every day but we've
been working on this project for about
six or seven months something like that
all right Krista Brown says to make
cards same height on profile card set
high to 100% okay cool I'm gonna alright
I was good about to try but maybe I want
to try it right now cuz I need to make
sure I get through these questions but
thank you for that
okay so Phoenix saying that the shortcut
he gave earlier was for selecting all
instances of that particular those
particular characters okay cool I'll
have to try that all right Christopher
says view is better but it's a little
weirder to learn than react okay
our sim says jQuery is still the best
hey I made a bunch of stuff in jQuery
before I learned react so I still have
things that I maintain that her jQuery
based
Krister says you're composed thing is
like SAS in JavaScript I like it that
way much easier to use Christopher says
jQuery isn't relevant anymore I don't
know I if you're building new stuff yeah
I'm not gonna use jQuery but there are a
lot of sites that are out there that use
jQuery so I guess it depends on what
you're working on like the odds of going
into an existing project and having to
use some jQuery are pretty good I mean I
don't know what the current stats are
but I mean it I think it's still the
majority of websites on the internet
have jQuery on them so yeah I would
never pick jQuery if I were making
something new but like I said I still
have to maintain sites at at jQuery so
it's definitely still good to know it
because you'll probably see it and and
work on it
and I mean shoot like before reacts and
all that I mean jQuery was where it was
at
Anoop says have you tried styled
components does it work with Internet
Explorer the last time I use styled
components was for react native so I
don't really I never tested it obviously
Internet Explorer so I'm not I'm not
sure about that does anybody know I
don't see why it wouldn't work you know
assuming that the content the markup
they gets spit out and actually sent to
the browser is something that Internet
Explorer could use I it definitely could
work skip monday says hello from Nigeria
hey how's it going thanks for watching a
mere says view combined angularjs and
react so if you know both I guess it's
fine such V if or ng if and mount
component did mount so as I said it's
best of both worlds Phoenix says I have
a tampermonkey script which checks for
jQuery on websites a lot of site still
has it
yeah sure Krister says the problem with
jQuery is that it contains a bunch of
bloat that you probably won't be using
and that slows down a lot of sites like
I was applying for a job and I checked
their site and it was slow I even did an
audit on it jQuery is the main problem
oh yeah for sure yeah like I said I'm
not gonna pick jQuery now for a new
project
but it's I wouldn't ignore jQuery in
terms of like knowing about it knowing
basics about jQuery just because like if
you're a freelancer and you work on
existing sites for people you're gonna
see jQuery right if you're going to go
work for a large company that's not like
one of the big tech companies you're
probably gonna work with jQuery right
there there are very few companies that
don't have jQuery going on somewhere
let's see Anoop says what are your
thoughts on the server-side render react
oh I almost always use server-side
rendering reacts because it's a must for
search engine optimization okay so I
there's a nice performance benefit on
initial load as well but mainly like you
need that server-side render rendering
for search engines to be able to see
your content if you're pulling it from
api's so yeah I definitely recommend
that and for me you know over the last
year - the easiest way to do that has
been just to use next jazz because it
has it it works automatically you don't
have to set it up
Ahmir says the fun part is angular uses
jQuery even it has internal JQ Lite
thing in it when jQuery is not available
yeah you're right
did they still have that I remember an
angular one they did have that that they
had their own version of jQuery built-in
Aamir says I decided to make my own
version of jQuery with es6 that's cool
Christopher says I preferred you as much
coding as possible in CSS so that the
JavaScript doesn't slow down the site oh
yeah for sure CSS is definitely more
performant than than JavaScript so it's
good to know all the ways you can use
CSS to do things that frequently do get
done with with JavaScript
crow says server-side rendering is not
better for a landing page and SEO
question mark I'm not sure what the
question is yes server-side rendering
yeah I'm not exactly sure what the
question is so just say like with
without server-side rendering if you're
trying to run a react app and you're
pulling your data in from an API these
the crawler right your search engine
BOTS that's going to go to your site
it's not going to stick around long
enough to wait for the data to come back
from that API call it's gonna look at it
and it's gonna see basically no content
whatever content you are pulling from
the API isn't going to be there so it's
not gonna index those things in search
so that's why you need to be rendered
server side and then will get sent to
the client is going to be HTML right
HTML CSS whatever you know so that's why
you you want that if you have a project
where you don't care about the SEO then
maybe you don't want to do server-side
rendering I've done projects where I
didn't need SEO so I didn't but you know
for me that's the main reason why I do
server-side rendering okay I've gotten
to the end of the chat just in time to
get some data prepared for my next
meeting and let's see all right we have
some further discussion in there about s
CSS and things like that okay all right
I'm an industry now I will probably
streaming in tomorrow thank you all so
much for watching and for all your help
in the in the live chat so get a little
bit done today not you know not totally
finished with this page but we got a
decent start and
you can check out remember you check out
the code the links in the description of
the video and if you have any questions
to check me out on in social media I
think my Twitter handles there if you go
to my youtube page which is linked I
have links to a lot of my other social
media things so whatever you're most
comfortable with just find me on there
and you know I'd be happy to help you
out with whatever you're working on so
until tomorrow have a great day